[Música]
Pablo Neruda publicó su primera
colección de poemas a los 19 años a lo
largo de su vida ganó el premio Nobel de
literatura rescató a dos mil refugiados
pasó tres años en exilio político y fue
candidato a la presidencia de chile
romántico y revolucionario Neruda fue
uno de los poetas más célebres del siglo
XX pero también uno de los más
accesibles y controvertidos
originalmente escritos en español en sus
poemas se emplea el lenguaje directo y
se relatan experiencias cotidianas para
crear un efecto perdurable
Neruda fue bautizado como Ricardo
eliezer Neftalí Reyes basualto en un
pequeño pueblo de chile en 1904 su padre
no quería que fuera poeta por lo que a
los 16 comenzó a escribir bajo el
seudónimo de Pablo Neruda
los poemas de su colección 20 poemas de
amor y una canción desesperada eran
tiernos y perceptivos a la vez que
iluminaban las sutilezas del amor y el
encantamiento en poema sexto por ejemplo
escribe tu recuerdo es de luz de humo
de estanque en calma Más allá de tus
ojos ardían los crepúsculos
posteriormente centró su poesía en la
apreciación de objetos cotidianos
muchos de los 225 poemas cortos de su
colección odas elementales se destinan a
la clasificación de los pequeños objetos
Aparentemente insignificantes que nos
rodean desde un par de cordones a una
sandía una cebolla es más hermosa que un
ave de plumas segadoras
y un atún en el mercado es una bala del
profundo océano proyectil natatorio te
vi muerto a pesar de sus primeros éxitos
literarios Neruda tuvo dificultades
económicas por lo que aceptó varios
trabajos diplomáticos en lugares como
birmania Indonesia Singapur y España en
1936 mientras Neruda trabajaba en el
consulado de Madrid estalló la guerra
civil y el gobierno fue derrocado por
una dictadura militar fascista
Neruda organizó la evacuación de
refugiados desde España a chile y salvó
así a 2000 personas durante 20 años
Neruda registró sus experiencias en el
extranjero en una colección de poemas
titulada residencia en la tierra muchos
de estos poemas eran experimentales y
surrealistas combinaban paisajes épicos
temáticas de los supernatural y
añoranzas con discusiones sobre disputas
políticas y la responsabilidad del poeta
de expresarse en contra de la injusticia
en explico algunas cosas se detienen
tormentosos detalles de la destrucción
de la Guerra Civil Española por el resto
de su vida Neruda permaneció
comprometido con sus ideales
revolucionarios debido a su posición
política estuvo exiliado Hasta 1952
cuando pudo regresar a Chile durante sus
años de exilio publicó su influyente
canto general aquí intenta contar la
historia de toda América Latina a través
de su poesía describiendo todo desde la
flora y la fauna hasta las políticas y
Las Guerras Pero principalmente homenaje
a la gente común responsable de los
logros de la civilización
tras regresar del exilio Neruda vivió el
resto de su vida en Chile
en 1970 a los 66 años Neruda fue
candidato a la presidencia de chile pero
renunció en favor de Salvador Allende
tras lo cual se convirtió en su
consejero pero en 1973 Allende fue
derrocado tras el golpe militar del
General Augusto pinochet Neruda murió en
el hospital una semanas después
debido a que esto se dio pocos días
después del golpe se rumoreaba que había
muerto de tristeza y hasta se decía que
había sido asesinado pero el hospital
registró que murió de cáncer
hoy día se recitan líneas de Neruda en
marchas y protestas de todo el mundo así
como su vida los poemas de Neruda
conectaban el romance con la revolución
al enfatizar los momentos cotidianos por
los que vale la pena luchar
[Música]
Explore la obra de otro icónico autor
relativo americano con este video o
sumerjas en la historia clásica del
torpe pero valeroso caballero del
renombrado autor Miguel de Cervantes con
este video
[Música]